bonsoir le président la république se
déclare favorable pour l'instant à une
consultation du parlement et non un
référendum pour une révision de la
constitution
nous effectuerons dans cette édition la
synthèse des propos radiotélévisée du
chef de l'état
les autres titres du 19/20 à l'ouverture
dans le calme d'eurodisney la victoire
de gilbert duclos lassalle dans paris
roubaix
et puis le cinéma après l'amour nouveau
film de diane kurys qui est notre invité
ce soir film qui réunit bernard
giraudeau il avait lu père et hippolyte
girardot
au cours de son intervention télévisée
ce soir le président la république s'est
donc montré favorable à une consultation
de l'assemblée nationale et du sénat en
faveur d'une révision de la constitution
révisions nécessaires à la ratification
des accords de maastricht et je ne
m'interdis rien je dis simplement il
faut ratifié je souhaite que les
assemblées facilite le travail de la
france pour cela il faut qu'ils
acceptent sur le ps et une big à sion
constitutionnel il faut qu'ils acceptent
la révision si c'est parlementaires sont
en mesure de réunir une majorité des
trois cinquièmes sur une obligation
constitutionnelle si on les textes de la
révision je vois pas pourquoi j'irais
compliquer les choses avec un référendum
merci tél mais n'est pas la volonté des
deux assemblées je me trouvais devant un
problème politique grave et bien entendu
je serai obligé de m'adresser à
l'ensemble des français pour trancher
mais on n'en est pas là alors premier
commentaire matin les travaux il n'y
aura donc pas de référendum pour
l'instant c'est pour l'instant
effectivement le président de la
république comme on s'y attendait
préfère la procédure parlementaire
d'abord pour réviser la constitution
comme le souhaite le conseil
constitutionnel et à ce moment là dit
président de la république voyons donc
si les assauts anglais joueront leur jeu
c'est à dire que le texte modification
doit être voté en termes identiques par
les deux assemblées puis ensuite réunis
congrès sans doute hélas le texte devra
être voté à la majorité des trois
cinquièmes donc le président de la
république dise est d'abord au parlement
a discuté et si effectivement il n'y
avait pas d'accord dans ce cas là alors
je jugerai et là évidemment on
retrouvera sur le problème du référendum
voilà donc procédure parlementaire
deuxièmement le président dit bien que
cette affaire européenne doit rester en
dehors des enjeux de politique
intérieure
ce n'est pas le décalque de nous
divisions dit le président de la
république en rappelant qu effectivement
le débat traverse tous les partis
politiques
précision en ce qui concerne le droit
donné aux européens de voter aux
élections européennes et aux élections
municipales dans le pays de la
communauté dans lequel ils résident
le chef de l'état indique qu'il faudra
sans doute pour les élections
municipales que ces citoyens de la
communauté résidé pendant un certain
temps pour avoir le droit de voter et
ils soulignent aussi qu'il faudra régler
le problème que poserait l'élection de
l'un d'eux à un poste de l'air ou de
maires adjoints puisque il deviendrait
ainsi grands électeurs dont tu aura sans
doute une demande d'exception formulée
par la france
enfin un mot tout de même en ce qui
concerne les élections récentes puis le
président de la république vient dire
qu'il s'était tenue volontairement à
l'écart du débat politique et qu'il
avait était donc contraint de changer de
premier ministre car madame cresson ne
bénéficiait plus des aides puisqu'elle
devait espérer
merci arlette chabot on vous retrouve
bien sûr d'ici une vingtaine de minutes
pour effectuer la synthèse de l'ensemble
des propos tenus ce soir par le chef de
l'état analysons et commentaires dans
une vingtaine de minutes politique
encore aujourd'hui le parti socialiste a
décidé de convoquer un congrès du 10 au
12 juillet pour préparer les élections
législatives de mars 1993 et en
repoussant à la fin de l'année prochaine
donc tout affrontement interne le
premier secrétaire du ps laurent fabius
a affirmé que ce congrès en juillet
serait un ampli congrès de rêve dans
quelques heures maintenant le paysage
audiovisuel français fermera les yeux
sur l'écran noir de la cinq six ans
après sa création la cinquième chaîne de
télévision française cessera à minuit
toutes ces émissions journée mélange de
deuil de nostalgie et d'humour noir
boulevard pereire alain chabod la cohue
dans les locaux de l'association de
défense de la saq toute la journée
téléspectateurs et curieux sont venus
nombreux pour vivre en direct les
dernières heures de la chaîne on signe
des bulletins d'adhésion et des chefs de
participation le moral n'y est pas je
regrette que d'être privés de télévision
particulière et vous ça vous fait un
pincement au coeur car bien sûr j'aurais
vers d'énormément mais comme beaucoup de
gens à l'extérieur c'est l'attroupement
sur les trottoirs le compte à rebours
vers l'écran loire a commencé vous avez
vu des gens que vous connaissiez la
sortir et rentrer ouais ça fait huit ans
claude bourret ça vous a fait plaisir
atmosphère détendue dans les studios
toute la rédaction prépare l'émission
spéciale de cette ultime soirée dans ici
chaque journaliste enregistre tour à
tour une météo humoristiques ont fait
contre mauvaise fortune bon coeur mais
avec des regrets et la mobilisation
c'est ça représente quoi pour vous les
grands noirs la suite tout à l'heure
pour l'instant pas grand-chose magie
risque impression que c'est un mauvais
rêve d'être victime d'une injustice mais
c'est la vie après tout il ya d'autres
personnes hier et demain qui vont perdre
leur boulot qui a pas de raison qu'on en
fasse plus pour la st à nous maintenant
de prouver qu'on n'était pas trop
mauvais et puis d'aller travailler soit
ailleurs soit dans votre entreprise dans
le jeu visuel voyons c'est ici en régie
finale qu'on a pu rassure le bouton dans
un peu plus de quatre heures des
dernières images disparaîtront pour
faire place au noir en telle une triste
première dans l'histoire de
l'audiovisuel
à l'étranger le petit espoirs d'accalmie
en bosnie herzégovine les représentants
de la communauté européenne ont annoncé
aujourd'hui la conclusion à sarajevo
d'un accord de cessez-le-feu entre les
parties en conflit
l'arrêt des combats devrait entrer en
vigueur demain à minuit commentaires de
philippe pisteurs les leaders des trois
principales communautés de bosnie
herzégovine ont solennellement à
accepter de déclarer un cessez le feu
sur toute l'étendue du territoire à
compter du dimanche 12 avril à minuit
aux termes de l'accord toutes les pièces
d'artillerie devrait être placé sous
contrôle des observateurs d'assez eux
les formations paramilitaires dissoute
et la mobilisation suspendu le tout
menant à des négociations sous l'égide
de la communauté européenne afin de
diviser la république en 3 région
autonome bai l'accord sur le papier mais
sur le terrain sarajevo
la tension reste vive à l'image de ce
point de contrôle serbe les miliciens de
chaque camp ne semble pas près
d'abandonner les armes
on ne peut pas faire confiance aux
musulmans et aux 3 de cette fois nous
allons montrer les dents et durement les
stars aiment les combats se poursuivent
pour l'instant la frontière avec la
serbie puis réfugiés eux ne prennent pas
de risques le flou direction la croatie
ne tarit pas en sicile le petit village
de da feira navy toujours sous la menace
des éruptions de l'etna malgré les
efforts des militaires la lave qui
s'écoule du volcan n'est plus maintenant
qu'à une centaine de mètres des maisons
le point avec anne-marie maso la lave
aux portes de la ville
cette coulées dévastatrices qui ce matin
a défoncé le dernier barrage érigé hier
par l'armée
l'état d'urgence décrété par le
gouvernement italien a permis de mettre
en place des opérations pour tenter de
dévier ou d'arrêter le flot première
partie de l'opération d'impressionnants
hélicoptères de la base américaine de
sigonella doivent déposer des blocs de
ciment de deux tonnes chacun à l'entrée
du tunnel de la deuxième phase dynamiter
les digues solides de lave sur le flanc
du volcan
malheureusement un épais brouillard
empêche pour l'instant de commencer ses
opérations
cet après midi
l'armée italienne a fait évacuer trois
maisons du village de sa ferrari mais
l'évacuation totale n'a pas été jugée
nécessaire
la coulée aurait ralenti sa progression
les habitants impuissants se retourne
contre le gouvernement de rome
il accuse de ne pas avoir réagi plus tôt
cela fait maintenant quatre mois que
l'etna s'est réveillée alors la
population prix nuit et jour devant
cette vierge de la providence selon la
légende il y a deux siècles la lave se
serait arrêté à ses pieds en france avec
une heure d'avancé sur l'horaire prévu
sans les embouteillages monstre annonçée
mickey accueilli aujourd'hui ses
premiers milliers de visiteurs au coeur
de son nouveau royaume magique européen
journée sans histoire pour sensation
américaine sabine born this way aux
adorateurs de la petite souris une vraie
famille française de bulletins la
première à s'être présenté au guichet ce
matin grâce à mickey et la gamine la
postérité et surtout un abonnement à vie
au royaume magique
comme elle des milliers d'anonymes venus
de toute l'europe ont fait le siège du
parc dès 6h ce matin
impatients de découvrir ce nouveau monde
à l'américaine
bienvenue au monde magic d'euro
disneyland pas plus organisés que mickey
une trentaine de caisses des sourires on
ouvre les portes une heure avant et le
tour est joué
225 francs l'entrée c'est cher mais le
rêve ça n'a pas de prix
un cadeau pour la vie
peut-être on espère se rappeler un peu
l'objet
on a vu les états unis et voilà mais
c'est magnifique
donc on a voulu être là aujourd'hui pour
le premier jour retrouver l'enfant
encore cours
une joie on est dans un moment et tant
pis pour les esprits chagrins cette
amérique de rêves colorés déguisé peuplé
de fées de personnages de dessins animés
les européens en redemande
dépaysement assuré par 29 attraction
très bien rodé ils étaient venus pour
les gosses ils sont au dessous de charme
subjugué par le souci du détail de la
machine 10 idées ça me paraissait deux
enfants tapent foire peu pacotille je
trouve que c'est très bien même sabot
montre agréable
moi je le vois taille adulte
enchanté comme les organisateurs qui
affiche ce soir un sourire satisfait
mais refuse de communiquer le nombre
d'entrées par superstition ce soir
l'oncle picsou va faire ses comptes bien
réel
en espérant que le bouche à oreille
marche à fond et que la petite souris
gagne son pari de 11 millions de
visiteurs par an auraient fausse note à
l'extérieur du parc un attentat à
l'explosif a coupé hier soir dans un
bois à marne-la-vallée un pylône
électrique supporter en trois lignes à
haute tension dont deux alimente le parc
de loisirs d'euro disney cette explosion
criminelle qui s'est produit à quelques
kilomètres du parc de loisirs pendant la
cérémonie d'inauguration n'a eu aucune
répercussion sur l'alimentation
électrique du site donc d'euro disney en
sport cyclisme gilbert duclos lassalle a
transformé aujourd'hui l'enfer du nord
en paradis vainqueur de paris roubaix à
l'âge de 37 ans le béarnais a signé un
authentique exploit dans une course qui
ne tolère ni la médiocrité ni la
malchance dominique sont pour le sourire
du vainqueur sous la colonne des
équipiers jamais un exploit aussi
personnel n'aura autant ressemblé à une
victoire d'équipé
en tout cas lui duclos-lassalle ce matin
l'avait prédit
et à l'heure où le peloton s'ébroue
encore sur les routes de l'oise
il se sent prêt à tenir sa promesse
devant pourtant quatre courageux ont
lancé la première véritable offensive
mais chacun sait bien que les premiers
secteurs pavés auront vite fait de
tempérer les ardeurs
en fait c'est dans la trouée d'arenberg
véritable chemin de croix de l'épreuve
que duclos lassalle va secouer son monde
et flanqué de ventes totales et van
snick il va récupérer un à un tous les
francs tireurs du matin à l'arrière le
peloton tire sa peine a presque trois
minutes
lemond école tu y joues aux équipiers
modèles etienne tout le monde tenait il
reste quarante sept kilomètres avant
roubaix et duclos lassalle oublions le
point de ses 38 ans est parti seul seul
sur les pavés dans la poussière avec
pour unique compagnie les encouragements
de roger legeay le complice de toujours
il y a une minute 40 à préserver sur un
seul homme qui n'a pas renoncé en la
flûte vig un allemand têtu qui n'échoue
vrac à 25 secondes seulement de duclos
lassalle
un médecin seconde on a toujours peur
d'une crevaison mais ça ça dure et le
lap d'une minute le lapd de faire 500
mètres parce qu'après je me suis dit
toute façon ils m'arrêtent sous les
pieds ce les socquettes on me dit dans
le terme cyclistes et puis j'ai dit à
trois kilomètres de l'arrivée
il faut qu'il roule deux fois plus vite
que moi donc j'ai dit il va pas revenir
tout de suite et puis quand j'ai vu ce
boulevard est la flamme rouge j'ai dit
maintenant c'est fini j'ai savouré le
plaisir non dissimulé d'une victoire
annoncée comme promis à madame ce matin
le bouquet sera pour elle et le pavé
souvenir pour l'acheminer et puis
football après sa victoire sur saint
seurin et hier soir bordeaux a
officiellement assuré son retour en
première division le club présidé par
alain afflelou accède ainsi à l'élite
deux jours seulement après
l'incarcération de claude bez dont la
gestion avait provoqué la chute des
girondins des débats l'aise grâce à son
succès 3 0 devant saint seurin bordeaux
gagne son billet pour la première
division
le héros de la soirée ernst auteur des
trois buts
le chaud et le froid souffle depuis
quelques jours sur la capitale girondine
après l'incarcération vendredi de claude
bez la mauvaise gestion de l'ancien
président avait en effet conduit au
dépôt de bilan et à la rétrogradation en
deuxième division
mais ce que le club a perdu en coulisses
une équipe de joueurs et de dirigeants
l'a conquis sur le terrain faire à
nouveau partie de l'élite
c'est extraordinaire on avait qui ce
soir un petit peu l'ambiance ici n'a le
coupe d'europe et une finale de coupe de
france c'est sûr qu'on va avoir besoin
de renforcer notre équipe pour jouer en
première division
on fera pas de folie mais on aura des
bons joueurs
on aura une grande équipe mais je
m'interdis de révéler quoi que ce soit
j'aurais pas par l'arrivée joueurs les
sponsors vont donc revenir l'argent va
affluer
mais loin de se laisser griser il semble
cette fois que les nouveaux responsables
soient bien décidé à gérer le budget
sans dilapider le cinéma maintenant plus
que jamais le nouveau film de diane
kurys après l'amour reflète l'air du
temps et les problèmes contemporains du
à travers le prisme des jeunes
générations cette fois ci nous sommes
confrontés aux histoires d'amour
parallèles dans lesquelles les
protagonistes s'embourbe à défaut d'y
voir clair dans leur véritable désir en
tête du générique est les trois
interprètes du film de diane kurys
isabelle huppert
bernard giraudeau et polis gerrard à
l'eau
euh non je prenais un café au bar
évidemment je suis tout ça
non pas très beau
et vient cette envie de venir elle
devrait traiter toute la journée mais tu
vas te promener siffle pas si j'ai envie
pourquoi je dis ça et à l'aéroport mais
quel aéroport à naples a pris l'avion
ouais si si c'est une très bonne
surprise si évidemment je suis tout seul
est pourquoi chercher là mais non je
suis pas bizarre à rennes
je t'envoie une voiture tu es sur ton
bras
escaladant une heure avec les enfants
alors henri chapier se fume
correspond-t-il à une sorte de
radioscopie contemporaine bien sûr du
comportement amoureux
oui tout à fait et c'est pourquoi je
suis persuadé qu y aura énormément de
monde parce que bon il est évident que
c'est un affront à notre population que
de supposer qu'il n'y a pas que des
couples fidèles bel eric vous le savez
que c'est vrai qu'elle est celui qui
n'éprouve une passion un moment donné le
fils de diane kurys feu paraît tout à
fait pointu sur un point d'ailleurs
voyez nous les hommes on en prend un peu
pour notre grade
d'abord on l'a vu là où viens de voir on
n'est pas exactement courageux au mot
assez facilement et de ce qui se dégage
quand même l'idée que les femmes
passionnait elles sont plus responsables
elles savent en général où elles vont
voilà mais c'est normal c'était le film
fait par une fable alors diane kurys à
votre avis c'est l'époque qui veut ça
nous sommes entrés dans une période
d'instabilité amoureuse il semble oui
vous avez remarqué comme c'est difficile
de dire je t'aime aujourd'hui vous en
connaissez beaucoup des hommes des
femmes qui disent qu'ils s'engagent
facilement dans une histoire d'amour
c'est compliqué et on sait plus très
bien mon ans d alors c'est ce qu'on a
essayé de faire dans ce film avec
antoine à combler ce de coscénariste on
a essayé de faire un constat de l'état
amoureux aujourd'hui mais de montrer
sans porter de jugement vraiment comment
les hommes et femmes vivent aujourd'hui
leur histoire d'amour et comment et
effectivement quelques fois ils trichent
quelques frais dit la vérité le mensonge
est inséparable à votre avis il est
fréquent en tout cas je crois ce qui est
admirable c'est la sérénité du
personnage d'isabelle huppert si d'abord
ça c'est assez extraordinaire et je me
demande si une femme pareille peut se
comporter comme ça alors c'est très
étonnant c'est une femme
qui a la chance d'être indépendante et
qui vit sa vie librement ses passions
librement fameux deux hommes
lm deux hommes qui sont eux aussi aimé
d'autres femmes c'est ça un petit peu
compliqué à raconter mais en gros c'est
une femme comme on en connaît beaucoup
il y en a des millions des femmes comme
ça alors dans des formes chose aussi qui
est très bien dans ce film ce qu a le
sentiment qu'ils sont sincères chaque
fois dans l'instant ils vivent avec elf
à m'ôter loeb
chacun des robes de votre film est
parfaitement sincère juste cet
instant-là quoi ben oui mais je crois
qu'ils sont juifs sont sincères au
moment où il aime et puis on sait plus
comment terminer les histoires d'amour
sais pas comment les vivres donc ils
sont à peu près dans ce dans ce
maelström qu'on vit constamment
cela dit il ya des personnages qui s'en
sortent un peu mieux que d'autres
personnages joués par yvan attal par
exemple il est il est plus disons qu'il
est peut-être plus pure entre guillemets
que le personnage joué par hippolyte
girardot ou même celui de bernard
giraudeau sondés si vous voulez quand
vous dites c'est un film de femmes c'est
vrai que les femmes la plupart du temps
est d'abord il ya pas beaucoup de femmes
cinéastes et la plupart du temps elles
montrent plutôt les femmes que les
hommes
et quand les hommes font des films avec
des hommes il se montre un petit peu
commune comme il voudrait être ici ce
n'est pas tel qu'ils sont c'est ce que
j'ai essayé de faire démontré tels
qu'ils sont alors vous avez c'est notre
sixième film vous avez réalisé des films
sur l'adolescence sur les hommes les
femmes l'a dit quels sont vos projets et
l regard allez vous braquez maintenant
sur la vie contemporaine
moi je sais pas je crois je vais
continuer à parler d'amour il n'y a pas
de plus beau sujet je crois merci diane
kurys après l'amour donc fait une
deuxième crise avec bernard giraudeau
hippolyte girardot et isabelle huppert
qui sort mercredi et sur vos écrans au
tour maintenant à l'actualité politique
et à l'intervention radiotélévisée du
chef de l'état elles ont effectué la
synthèse des propos tenus par françois
mitterrand voici d'abord le premier
commentaire du président la république
sur le résultat des élections régionales
et cantonales
ce qui est vrai lionel jospin dit est
vrai c'est que la majorité
présidentielle a reculé en somme c'était
pas tout à fait la première fois mais
c'est la première fois de façon aussi
sensible ainsi point les choses
tirons-en les conséquences et essayons
de nous faire mieux comprendre les
français c'est ce que nous allons faire
avec le gouvernement de permis
je regrette d'avoir été conduits à le
faire car j'ai j'avais j'ai toujours
grande confiance dans les qualités
d'edith cresson qui ne mérite pas les
injustices dont elle a pu souffrir mais
si c'était vrai l issue des élections
municipales et régionales et vous une
série de phénomènes qui était entraînée
par ces deux résultats que le
gouvernement ne trouvait plus les appuis
dont il avait besoin
combien celui de l'échangé et j'espère
que ce nouveau gouvernement réussira
tout le monde pense que des européens
qui ne seraient pas nationaux français
vivant en france et qui seraient
appelées selon le texte du traité à
voter pour les élections européennes ce
qui va de soi les ou à voter pour les
élections municipales pour les élections
municipales
normal d'exiger une certaine durée de
présence que ce soit en soi pas rêver la
veille qu'on soit là depuis plusieurs
années qu'on soit vraiment sinon
assimilés du moins intégrés entrée dans
la communauté ou s'agira de vivre
ensuite je prendrai des précautions
parce que certains aspects
constitutionnels se pose principal le
conseiller municipal france à deux
petits points parmi d'autres pouvoirs en
a deux qui touche à notre constitution
il flotte pour l'élection des sénateurs
ont des sélections strictement nationale
et d'autre part les maires par exemple
ont des pouvoirs dispose de pouvoirs de
police par délégation de l'état au nom
de l'état et l'état français
donc il serait pas possible une étrange
et de les exercer
il faut pouvoir élire des étrangers si
les français ne décide dans la commune
où il vit
c'est déjà une épreuve c'est du citoyen
qui différent celui là ça fait
maintenant cinq ans dix ans qu'il est
parmi nous une très sympathique
il peut nous apporter quelque chose on
les lui conseiller municipal ça se
regarde mais ensuite pour les lire mais
roux
délégué sénatoriales la question se
reposer nous avons le droit de la pause
et le président la république a
également estimé que bernard tapie
nouveau ministre de la ville
représentait une réussite et il a
déclaré qu'il ressentait avec tristesse
la dégradation des moeurs publiques
analyse de l'ensemble des propos du chef
de l'état arlette chabot on retiendra
bien sûr le credo en l'europe du
président la république
oui tout à fait au fond il n'y a pas de
vraie surprise dans ses déclarations du
président de la république
confirmation c'est qu'ils souhaitent
évidemment reprendre l'offensive et
l'initiative sur son terrain qui est
celui de l'europe avec les entreprises
que constitue la ratification du traité
de maastricht alors certes il tire les
conséquences des élections régionales et
cantonales il dit bien qu'il a été un
regret obligé de se séparer d'edith
cresson il assume lui-même l'échec
il a nommé pierre bérégovoy mais en
quelque sorte il dit maintenant c'est à
pierre bérégovoy de travailler et donc
il tourne un peu la page et s'avance sur
le terrain européen en confirmant une
chose c'est qu'il préférerait pour la
ratification de ce traité de maastricht
emprunter la voie parlementaire mais si
évidemment le sénat et l'assemblée eut
refusé la majorité nécessaire
il pourrait se tourner vers les français
et donc organiser un référendum mais
pour l'instant là encore il se laisse du
temps pour voir donc le président
souhaite aujourd'hui ouvrir une nouvelle
page c'était attendu et donc pas de
surprise merci arlette chabot à 22h30
réactions analyses commentaires après
les propos du chef de l'état avec
arlette chabot nous recevrons elisabeth
guigou bernard bosson et nicolas sarkozy
tout de suite la météo de michel touré a
tout à l'heure 22h35 pour soir 3 merci
non